الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين يطلق العنان لغزو
عسكري واسع النطاق متعدد الجوانب ،
لا توجد مدينة آمنة تم
الإبلاغ عنها في 16 موقعًا على الأقل في
أوكرانيا في جميع أنحاء من كييف إلى ماريوبول أوديسا
في الجنوب على طول الطريق غربًا إلى
لا فيف.
وزارة الشؤون الداخلية الأوكرانية
تظهر الأضرار الناجمة عن عملية تفجير
بالقرب من كييف بعض من 3
ملايين مواطن ينتزعون
ممتلكاتهم الفارين غربًا في سياراتهم في
هذا النزوح الجماعي من العاصمة
، حصلت CNN على هذا الفيديو الحصري
من حرس الحدود الأوكراني وهنا
يمكنك مشاهدة الجيش  مركبات هذه هي
مركبات عسكرية روسية تدخل
أوكرانيا من بيلاروسيا في الشمال. ذهب
الرئيس بوتين
على شاشة التلفزيون الحكومي وأعلن عن عملية عسكرية خاصة
كما يسميها
قائلاً إنها لحماية منطقة دونباس
، والهدف الذي يقول إنه
نزع السلاح وإظهار
دلالة  أوكرانيا جزء من السياق هنا على
الرغم من أن رئيس أوكرانيا فلاديمير
زيلينسكي يهودي
أوكراني  تم إخبارهم بالبقاء في
منزلهم ، لكن هذه المجموعة الصغيرة
شوهدت راكعة وتصلي في شوارع
رئيس أوكرانيا زيلينسكي من
أجل السلام في خطاب متلفز على المستوى الوطني
قبل لحظات فقط
أعطني الأهمية التاريخية
لهذه اللحظة لرؤية
ما بعد العالم  لقد انقلب أمر الحرب الثانية حقًا
أمام أعينكم هذا
الصباح ، وما نراه الآن هو
محاولة من جانب روسيا
لإبادة أوكرانيا بشكل أساسي كدولة مستقلة
ذات سيادة من نوع حروب الغزو الإمبريالية
التي لم نرها أه
أنت تعرف في  منذ الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي ،
ما الذي تعتقده حقًا أن
الأوكرانيين سيفعلونه حيال ذلك ، ما مدى قدرتهم
على التراجع
جيدًا ، أعتقد أنه سيكون
تحديًا للقوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
أه أن تقاوم فقط لأن روسيا
ملتزمة بالتفوق الجوي كما تعرف
أوكرانيا  لم يتم توفير
دفاعات جوية كان يطلب من شركائها الغربيين
أه لبيعها
لذلك في معركة تقليدية أه روسيا
بالتأكيد لديها مغزى ساحق
ومع ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أن هناك شيئًا واحدًا هو
أخذ هذين العقدين والسكان
في مدن مثل كييف
يعارضون بشدة الرئيس بوتين
والاحتلال الروسي للبلاد ، لذا
ستكون هناك مقاومة
بالتأكيد سيكون هناك تمرد في وقت
لاحق وهذا الإرادة  لا تنتهي أه بغزو سريع
غير دموي ، لقد رأينا
صورًا من المدينة حيث
أنت الآن في طوابير طويلة من
الناس الذين يحاولون الفرار إلى
الجزء الغربي من البلاد ما هو
المزاج هناك في الشوارع
جيدًا بالبدلات  فارغة أه تعرف أني
أستطيع أن أشم الآن هذا النوع من
أه دخان المستندات المحترقة أه
هناك قطع من الرماد تطفو في
الهواء أه من مكاتب حكومية قريبة أه
هناك الكثير من الاحتياط أه في
تمويه في الشوارع
متصلين  الوحدات أه بسبب استدعاء
جنود الاحتياط
وإه تعلم أن المحلات لا تزال مفتوحة
الناس عالقون في الطعام الناس
يحصلون على النقد من أجهزة الصراف الآلي
والناس مذهولون فقط
يمكن أن يحدث شيء من هذا
القبيل حقًا لم يصدقه أحد حتى
اللحظة الأخيرة